different after I am not so certain how
I am going to find a boyfriend things
are definitely gonna change there's a
lot of spit flying around there change
now we can interact with people in the
future we've had times which were much
more rough than this pandemic the
humanity state the way it was hello my
name is yaara Zeiten and I'm an opera
singer currently based in Vienna Austria
I think things are definitely gonna
change because there's a lot of spit
flying around there you know on the
stage when you're singing super loud or
in the brass section and the pits of the
orchestra you know they're always
releasing their spit on time so I think
people are just gonna conduct the same
things you know the rehearsals but have
hygiene take much more importance I'm
huntin I'm living in the south and
friends say think that the biggest
consequences is the changes about custom
Princeton's we are used to make the bees
it's a kiss in order to say hello to
people I think the whole Mediterranean
region people like body-contact to
salute each other like hugging kissing
and for now people are a bit more
cautious cause a little bit scared of
what happened but I'm sure this will go
back to its origins slowly but surely
because I think it's in our blood
my name is Tim Pia to see
a Township called Alexandra in South
Africa I worry a lot about the future of
social distancing because it means they
won't be hiking and touching I find it
hard to last in social distancing
because I'm used to hiking in such a
severe Arkana virus the fear to be close
to someone else will bring an end to the
to the bill I've never been as in touch
with my family back home as I have
during the past four months thanks to
the internet I don't know how much so
how I am going to find a boyfriend I
don't know for sure how I do that just
because I'm busy business you all the
time but on the other side I decided
that yeah I won't be single forever
so the dating scene
I guess I get to be maybe worried about
the dating scene because social
distancing and the pandemic is not
exactly the best situation for a love
story my way of life means that I don't
interact with people events like parties
I don't go to clubs the only opportunity
to meet someone is during my studies
over at my work being extremely focused
on my work and studies makes me a bit
immune to the worries about the dating
scene I guess we'll see I know that I do
not want to be single for the rest of my
life
especially due to covert 19 the chance
of online dating is even higher a lot of
people are getting offended by the fact
that you say that they're they have
coronavirus if they are coffee this
makes my society pick up fights and get
to argument amongst relationships during
this lockdown I experiencing quite
accusation
because mistakes are easy picking up and
also this creates a lot of unnecessary
autonomous financial problems are also
an issue especially if both are partners
I am Dave and I'm Kareem and we're here
in ubud in Bali with our twin boys who
are two and a half years of age the
people is a bicycle community with the
boys which they really need the social
distancing and the masks is I think
quite damaging for young children we
really don't have an understanding of it
from a future perspective if this to
last too much longer I think that it
will be quite destructive for young
children and we are worried about that
and we're hoping they very soon the
covert 19 crisis led us to being fairly
alone or I didn't want him to be alone
just because I knew was just one year of
age we actually had one friend that we
met in the beginning they didn't need
that much that has changed now we are
actually right here
at this point together so the kids
actually learned not to touch anyone
this I think is very dangerous even for
our society because the closeness that I
find important for a good relationship
with people and also all over the world
is gone this web address is now open and
by appointment only you have to wear
face masks industry now switch on my
face mask here but obviously I want my
beard dude I'm gonna have to get it
taken off it looks like a massive dental
experiment so here I'm in the barbers
getting all get all dressed up don't
have to wear masks but there is muster
hey hey at least I get a haircut which
is you know makes you feel good so it's
very important also disinfect in the sea
full mask apron gloves then this is the
new headdresses it's quite good because
I don't have to queue up so I'm really
empty seat so I'm really really happy
there we go finish guys gracias
I'll hopefully safely good know Jews
being spread and feeling comes better
she gets those hairdressers guys hasta
luego adios
I think hygiene you will generally
approved across the world
I can't envision a scenario in which
people go back things as normal once you
know the corona virus stops being a
problem to the degree that it is right
now people are always gonna be conscious
with handshakes and germs and ways to
protect themselves things like for
example washing your hands when you come
home from outside is gonna start being
standard practice which it hasn't been I
don't think that social distancing is
gonna remain as it is forever but I do
think that we're gonna need probably
like a year or two before things go back
to will people want to be in a big opera
house with two thousand people or ten
thousand people I hope yes but also it
would be understandable if people are
more cautious about going to you know
big events with many people in them
[Music]